la orden del gobierno de parar
totalmente la industria de la
construcción durante dos semanas
desencadenó la jornada de protestas en
melbourne cerca de 2000 personas
salieron a manifestarse en contra de
esta decisión dice el gobierno del
estado de victoria que tuvo que tomarla
porque la mitad de los sitios de
construcción inspeccionados no están
cumpliendo las normas sanitarias contra
el cob y 19 de hecho hay 443 casos
activos en 186 sitios de construcción
del gobierno por eso además ordenó que
desde el 23 de septiembre todos los
trabajadores de la industria deberán
tener al menos una dosis de la vacuna
por eso en medio de las protestas ellos
dicen que la vacuna debe ser algo
voluntario y no algo obligatorio las
protestas fueron en gran parte pacíficas
pero hubo también altercados
enfrentamientos violentos principalmente
con la policía en este parque en cartón
gardens hubo un ataque en contra de
varios vehículos de la policía dice
justamente la policía del estado de
victoria que hubo 44 arrestos un
periodista resultó herido al igual que
tres policías y también hubo numerosos
daños materiales en propiedades privadas
y también vehículos oficiales espera que
las protestas continúen en los próximos
días